nous partons immédiatement à la
faute-sur-mer en vendée une station
balnéaire en deuil
vingt-sept personnes ont perdu la vie
sans compter les disparus
elisabeth venait dans ce lotissement de
la faute sur mer au sud de la vendée
les pompiers se relaient depuis ce matin
pour sauver les habitants
on sait déjà que le bilan est très lourd
vingt-sept personnes au moins sont
mortes
prisonnière de la montée des eaux elles
ont atteint par endroits 2 mètres 50
les habitants racontent comment ils ont
été surpris dans leur sommeil par la
rapidité et la violence de la tempête
je me suis aperçu en mettant au pied par
terre qu'il y avait un petit peu un
petit peu d'eau et le temps de réveiller
tout le monde de récupérer genre les
papiers enfin bon certains documents
téléphone quand on est monté à l'étagé
puis la porte a cédé et en l'espace
d'une demi-heure
la maison s'est remplie les pompiers
puissent courir 600 personnes mais
plusieurs habitants sont encore coincés
à l'étagé de leur maison
j'attends que on sauverait parents je
comprends pas la publication ce matin
bonjour papa saba ils sont bloqués dans
leurs valeurs m'en sers depuis 4 heures
ce matin ils sont pas secourus non cola
je suis très inquiète très inquiète
parce qu'on m'a dit que la halle à
marées à les remonter
donc ils ont pu électricité plus rien
sont plus de 70 ans la plupart des
habitants ont pu être évacués dans un
gymnase d'une commune voisine qui
s'apprête à les recevoir
les pompiers poursuivent leurs
opérations de pompage mais des risques
d'inondation subsistent avec une grande
marée attendue ce soir